Welcome back.
I'm here with the queens of clean
who have organized spaces for some of our favorite stars
like Reese Witherspoon, Retta,
Chris Pratt, Neil Patrick Harris
and here to debut the season two trailer
of their hit series, The Home Edit.
And spoiler alert, I get to be on it this season too.
I'm so excited.
Please, welcome back to our show,
our dear friends, Clea Shearer and Joanna Teplin!
Thanks for having us!
Aw, I'm so happy to be with
you guys.
Oh my God,
we're so happy to be back.
Oh my gosh.
I get to do the show,
we get to do this show together.
It's amazing.
Now, would you guys like to do the honors
of taking us into, you know?
Clea.
Okay.
Clea, you do it.
All right, here's an exclusive first look
at The Home Edit season two trailer!
Roll it!
Was the um, oh hi!
(women screaming)
I'm Clea.
And I'm Joanna.
We are professional organizers.
Post Get Organized on Netflix. Everything changed overnight.
We have clients all over the country,
including some celebrities.
Why?
Oh my gosh.
How do you do what you do?
Wow.
They have this way about them
that adds a magic to the entire space.
This space has just been overwhelming.
Okay.
Welcome to the chaos.
I literally have like a million props.
I mean, that's why you guys are here.
Challenge accepted.
♪ Clean up everybody ♪
♪ Everywhere ♪
♪ Clean up ♪
No, you missed that line.
No, that, I don't know.
No, no, you're wrong.
(upbeat music)
(people screaming)
Wow.
I went through the process of this show
because this stuff was overtaking my house.
And my family's space is getting smaller and smaller.
And we would love nothing more than
to give you back your home.
Okay. Don't fall.
Nope.
The pressure is extremely on.
We've never been fully taken down by a project
but there's always a first for everything too.
Oh my God. Are you okay?
Joanna, are you okay? What happened?
I'm such a failure.
You're drinking soy sauce and you're eating salt.
You made a big old failure by drinking wine and champagne.
Are you serious right now?
This is amazing!
(upbeat music)
There it is.
This calms my anxiety in a way that I can't quite explain.
Oh!
(upbeat music)
I just...
(Clea and Joanna laughing)
I'm not kidding.
You are so sweet.
Oh, thank you!
(audience cheering)
Yes. I can't believe I get to butt in that trailer.
I get so emotional watching that, you know?
What is one of the highlights of this season for you?
One of the most fun things is we got to work
with almost every single person in our team
was on the show.
So we were able to collaborate
with so many incredible organizers who work for us.
Trust me, Joanna and I are the B team at this point.
Totally.
And it was just so fun and working on projects like yours,
which was just incredible.
Had so many--
Spaces outside of the home, you know?
Yeah, I meet so many incredible clients.
I mean, last season too, but this season, it just,
it was incredible to meet people all over the country
that are struggling with needing organizational help.
And I have to say, so rewarding.
Well, good.
It's fun,
but it's gonna make your life better.
It really does.
And you guys are just the greatest.
Okay, Clea and Joanna, season two of The Home Edit
premieres April 1st on Netflix.
I'll be binging it or savoring it and everything in between.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you so much!
(upbeat music)